Dr. John Halamka is
the Chief Information Officer of Beth Israel Deaconess Medical Center in Boston,
Chairman of the New England Health Care Exchange Network,
Co-Chair of ONC's HIT Standards Committee,
a full professor at Harvard Medical School,
a practicing emergency physician,
and an accomplished farmer.
In late 2014, he announced the Argonaut project,
a private collaboration in which each of
the participants agreed that all specifications and
artifacts developed would be openly available via an open content license.
Since the participants included many of
the largest health IT vendors and leading health care systems,
this was a very significant development.
The three initially proposed and now posted deliverables are,
FHIR Data Query Profiles,
a set of FHIR resources and accompanying profiles that enables
query/response of the discrete data elements
contained in the Meaningful Use Common Data Set.
FHIR Document Query Profile.
A FHIR resource and profile that enables
query/response of Cross-Enterprise Document Sharing XDS,
a specification for managing the sharing of
documents between healthcare provider organizations.
XDS is commonly used by health information exchanges to connect to EHRs.
Security Implementation Guide,
based on the SMART on FHIR OAuth 2 and OpenID Connect profiles.
These are the key tools for establishing
identity and access rights to data for SMART and FHIR apps.
We will discuss this in more detail in the next lesson.
Two newer deliverables are the Scheduling Implementation Guide.
This supports basic patient and provider
access to providers calendar and appointment requests,
including APIs and guidance for searching and publishing a provider schedule,
and requesting, canceling, or updating an appointment.
CDS Hooks Implementation Guide.
Argonaut is developing use cases,
providing guidance and publishing an implementation guide for deploying CDS Hooks.
Argonaut leverages the data access framework we mentioned earlier,
and it's compatible with prior interoperability efforts.